need motivation what a top 10 with
belief nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something greater
inside you as well you've got Michael
Jordan level talent add something so get
ready to find good mentors find your
purpose and get good habits with Terry
Crews and my take on his top ten route
success vol 4 to give you the belief
that you need
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one remove temptation remove temptation
you must remove temptations if you are
going to have self-discipline I'm trying
to say if you are trying to lose weight
if you are trying to get better if you
are trying to do things in a good good
way you have to remove the temptations
me I had a problem with pornography
years ago and now it's one of those
things that I had to eliminate
temptations I had to eliminate things
that I felt would trigger me and get me
back or going on the wrong path and it's
really really subtle one of the things
is by examining what the way you think
and how you act in a given situation I
find it there were times like Friday
night is when I felt like that was the
time to view pornography you know why
because I remember everyone going out on
Friday and it feeling real sexy and
feeling like whoo and women and this
dancing and partying and all that and
then I would I would do it I've said no
I'm not gonna do that I'm a good boy but
I'm gonna stay home and I'm gonna watch
porn which was a horrible horrible habit
so Friday night I know when those
feelings are coming and when that I get
sensitive and I feel like mmm you know
this might be the time to click on
something you know what I mean and I
know it and I headed off at the path you
just make sure that you know where you
are and you avoid those temptations the
same thing with eating if you know
you have a problem with donuts do not go
to the donut shop to get your coffee you
know I mean go to a place that doesn't
have Donuts or something that you know
is your vice that you know you shouldn't
do rule number two find mentors 6-day
was your first film audition book that
first because what they were looking for
a tough guy yeah they were looking for a
tough guy and I was coming off battle
dome I had the reputation and but the
thing is it was cool too because it was
Sony so you know it's kind of in the
Sony family you know hey this guy over
here he's real tough and so I went in
and the lady was like the consolation
like you're pretty good are they okay
probably hitting on me I don't know
never had done a movie and I was like
well if I get this that would be great
and they literally told me Terry you got
the movie and I'm going okay well I went
home I said I was gonna kill me because
I was thinking you know I get two days
on a movie I'm gonna shoot me and then
I'll be a dead body and it'd be great
you know I I'm thinking it's a
little-bitty role it's not a big deal
first of all it was a main role yeah I
had no idea you gotta say I had no idea
how this whole thing went so I was
taft-hartley into sad ok because with
this show that we were doing was after
at the time and they were all split it
was no sag after it was just two
different things and so I was like oh my
god like I blew up the Vancouver then I
do you're gonna be here for like four
months
like what like I'm in all these scenes
and I remember cuz they didn't show us
the script they didn't have it we didn't
have it was just a little bitty parts
and I was like oh my god I'm in all this
movie and then I got scared cuz I'm
and what was funny is that they were
like okay Terry we're not gonna use you
for two weeks so you can go back home to
LA and I'm like no no I'm good I'm good
I stay here I'll stay here because I was
so used to getting cut in the NFL mmm
that I felt like oh no they're gonna
replace me yeah and so you're talking
about just panicky panicky I didn't know
what to do I was like oh man no I'll
stay out it and I remember sitting in my
room for two weeks straight it's just
literally waiting for them to call me
when I couldn't went home the whole time
now they're like you got a half a day
I'm like I'm at home I want to play I'm
back with the kids and no but that back
in the day I didn't know and one of the
best people of all time I mean to this
day Michael Rooker was on the movie yeah
and Michael taught me how to do
everything like hit a mark oh he was a
sectarian when I move in here
he said Jerry you when I go to split you
I need you to just kind of take my place
right there how guide you through this
thing man it's gonna be good and I'm
telling you that I mean to this day
Mike it's the probably one of the most
special people in my whole life
yeah because every time I see him he's
just I'm so proud of you mad at me and
I'm just like dude you gave me all the
tools he gave me all the keys you said
cheering you got an itch if you have an
inch scratching in the middle of the
scene he says cuz you should you gotta
live it just go ahead and do it that I
would be like no
I'm scaled my god I know I know Terry
yeah well Allah and he was just showing
me this is like your acting class
haven't really studied you know I hadn't
done anything yeah I hadn't done
anything but I what my thing was I was
open because I needed this to work rule
number three find your purpose once you
know your purpose your direction is
clear there will be no confusion I'm
gonna its Wow
but there were times in my life I didn't
know where I wanted to go I didn't know
what I wanted to do but you know why
because I didn't know my purpose I had
no idea what I was supposed to do I
remember I remember retiring from the
NFL and I was like you know I'm too good
to go out there and get any job but my
purpose was to take care of my family
but I was sitting up on the couch
ah you know what it's all gonna be good
it's not a problem I'm telling you it's
shameful it was a shameful and I
remember us running out of money and I
have to dig in the couches and try to
find money for milk for my kids and I
was missing my purpose I was in
confusion and one day my wife came to me
she's done honey you need a job I'm like
you know what I can't just go out there
and do any job you know I was in the NFL
you know that and she said well you know
what I don't care that you enough uh we
need some milk we need to eat we need
gas what are you gonna do and my first
job I remember I was humbled solo my
first job in LA I went to a place called
labor ready and I showed up at 5:00 in
the morning and there were ex-cons
there were drug addicts there were all
kind of people there and they would give
you a job for the day for eight hours
and I remember making $8 an hour for
eight hours and they would send me all
over there so you got a car I was like
yeah I got one but you gonna go over
here and you're gonna work in this
factory and I
remember grabbing that broom picking it
up and I started sweeper and I remember
feeling lowered and low I was like man
and again here comes the pity party I
was in the NFL I was running around with
big stars I was doing it making money
doing all this stuff and Here I am
sweeping the floor and it was horrible
and I felt miserable but then all of a
sudden something happened I was sweeping
I started to realize that I was doing
something about my situation that
instead of sitting around talking about
it instead of sitting around wondering
where my opportunity was telling as well
I was proactive and let me tell you
something I was fulfilling my purpose I
got the money for my family and I
realized that I am NOT going to just sit
ever again and that was the turning
point in my life in a major major way
once I found out what my purpose was
you'd do anything in your purpose and
you still stay there and you can be
you'll be 100% on the right path rule
number four get good habits I love to
work out so but some people get out of
shape and they feel bad and they say man
you know it works like shame it's the
same thing so you you you or you feel
like man I can't I'm overweight I feel
bad what happens it's those cycles just
keep going you feel bad so what happens
so you feel better you eat again and
then you feel bad in the gym because
people are looking at you and you gonna
look good in my pants and I'm just on
your look in the mirror and you go man
as fat is still here and the whole thing
and Fitness is way over there it's
somewhere I gotta go and it's - it's a
across the country and it's so long I
give up you know what I'm gonna just sit
down here eat another donor
and let me tell you that's real but
Fitness is in you in you the whole time
that fit body is there and you think
it's way over there and that's the lie
so the lie is another guy comes into gym
he walks in like hey man you can't lift
that and he walks by you feel shame
again but you don't let nobody do that
to you I'm here to tell you and fitness
it's one thing that you say you know
what I am fit even if you see it I am
fit and you know what fit people do but
people go to the gym fit people don't
eat doughnuts bit people eat protein and
let me tell you something we we had free
doughnuts today now I want to bring that
up I want to bring that up too I want to
bring that up which is awesome I have my
cheat days I love donut but I'm here to
tell you this that you don't become what
you want you become where your habits
take you now you have a doughnut you
ain't gonna get fat but you have a
hundred doughnuts over a course of years
you will end up fat and you say how did
I get back this people who want money
people say I want money I want money I'm
gonna go get my money and then but your
habits don't give you any money also if
you want to have more confidence check
out my 254 series they're free the links
to join are in the description below you
gotta get rid of those haters in your
mind whatever you're thinking about it
you will not get it until you take a
[ __ ] rule number five give it a shot my
first job in LA was sweeping floors I
mean we went broke after the NFL I was a
journeyman the whole thing
and what the thing is when I left
football I was like you know yeah
Hollywood they waiting for me every
athlete that you know Hollywood career
is just ever is waiting but you never
ever noticed that no one who's ever went
before you ever made it it's like every
year every every every NFL athlete NBA
he thinks it's ready but you notice that
there's nobody else in front of you
that's doing it so I got a chance to
Amman literally was sweeping floors
because I ran out of money and then I
got an upgrade by doing security on
motion pictures and movies the first
movie I ever did security for was man on
the moon with Jim Carrey and we talked a
little bit and I remember all that all
this is a movie said it was right down
the street on Wilshire at the Ambassador
Hotel the old Ambassador they raised it
now but that was back where they had two
Academy Awards and hood I mean I do own
a history I was like oh you know I'm a
fan but I'm like I'm working in the
business this is Hollywood that's Jim
Carrey it but he wouldn't let anybody
call him Jim at the time to call me Andy
he was like yeah it was Andy I want to
use the highway sir and he walked by he
was totally like Andy Kaufman and I was
like this is crazy and so I still was
broke and
while I was doing all this stuff a
friend of mine was like hey man look on
your day off you know there's a show I'm
working on it's called battle dome they
have auditions down in Venice Beach and
maybe you should go and I'm like I told
my wife I'm like I had my only day off
from the security stuff and I said and I
was trying to get behind the scenes to
be honest with you
I didn't want to be in front I had
scripts I'd written my my portfolio was
in a Disney level an artist painting
drawing the whole thing and I was just
like I'm going to be a creator you know
and my wife was like I asked her I said
should I try this and she was like honey
we have nothing so I mean just go for it
I went down to Venice Beach and I was in
shape and I started a little they had us
doing all these things running jumping
you know we were we were climbing up
ropes they wanted to act like you know
be a wrestler and the whole thing and
all and everybody was like they were
like you're pretty good I was like
thanks and then I went home and I told
my wife I never forget the day I came
back and we had a little bitty house in
Burbank it was literally one room and
what you would call a bedroom but it was
all unopened and I remember going in
that little house and I was like honey I
did really good like I feel like that
was something special like I don't know
what's gonna happen but I like rule
number six don't operate out of pride
getting more and more popular and
everybody was like Terry Crews you still
amazing Terry Crews oh just do it girl
you're so great
and I kept getting this I died for my
wife like
[Music]
and I'm like I'm looking but I can
always feel the eyes burning and it
started you know when your wife is like
yeah he all that right you know and I
said okay I gotta bust this bubble the
bubble needed to be burst like it was my
head was all big and everything but I
had to let people know that I am NOT all
that in this regard I'm just like
everybody else and this is the biggest
biggest thing especially with men you
know we we operate off pride we go off
of hey man I bet you won't jump off that
bridge
I'll bet you I will and guys we operate
that way because I'll pry it's one of
those things that activates us you know
that's why when you see more than three
or four guys going somewhere it's
usually somewhere stupid you know if
something bad is about to happen there
are stairs no no watch this and I was
like oh man and the pride that we have
is something that could really really
hurt us
because what happens is as you're built
up and everyone's eyes and everyone is
now saying you're the man and you're
this and this that you don't want
anything to ruin that you start to love
that even though in your personal life
it's messed up even though at home
everybody knows the real you but you
keep the picture because now it's not
about it's about a brand I'm Terry Crews
the brand I am a brand now I am I am an
image and I have an image to uphold
and it's really pride it's really I bet
you won't jump off that bridge and what
happens is it will collapse with that
image you become better than everyone
else you are now you're you floating
here I mean you literally like and
you're better than other people this is
where you you see I've seen stars I've
seen athletes I'm seeing ministers I've
seen all kind of different people who
literally dog out people below him
because I'm better than you
I really believe I am worth more than
you ah me Terry Crews I believed I was
more valuable than my wife and kids I
did I'm being real with you I was like
you know my wife were coming to me on my
you know I whatever you have to say I'm
the boss you know my way or the highway
the kids would have something to say I
might you know what be quiet you know in
fact shut up out and they will walk away
and you treat everybody like that
because you're better you feel you're
better I'm worth more than you and what
happened is that you eventually fall you
eventually lose the job you eventually
lose your money you eventually have to
you are going to take a loss now the
most dangerous part about this though is
because when you become your wins when
you're floating it high and all that you
inevitably have to become your losses
you have to be if you live by those
rules you have to lose rule number seven
halt you know in therapy there was a
call there was a phrase that we used to
use all the time called halt
H a LT and that means when you are
hungry angry lonely or tired you have to
be really really conscious of what's
happening it's called halt any time
you're hungry angry lonely tired halt
look at what you're doing examine it if
you're hungry get something to eat if
you're angry calm down think about where
you are get yourself in a good mood if
you are lonely call a friend call
someone you know talk about these things
talk about your emotion talk about how
you're feeling and if you are tired
get some rest because that is when your
weakest all of those four states of
being is when you are at your weakest
spot rule number eight be the best
version of yourself very crude my job my
main main purpose is to be the best
husband father and friend I can be that
is my main purpose but now I have to go
deeper than that how can I be a better
friend how can I be a better friend
sometimes people think Oh being a better
friend means that when people want money
you give it to them no sometimes it
means you tell people no that's being a
good friend sometimes it means you give
some tough love you have to go to
somebody and say hey you know I didn't
like what you've said that to me I don't
like the way you are doing that you're
being mean to people you this is
sometimes being a good friend being a
good father is now all about going to
Disneyland being a good father is
sometimes training your kids the ways to
go being a good husband is really about
putting your wife first and really
taking responsibility for everything
that role entails now it goes that
weight on your job too
rule number nine don't compete with
others Katt Williams and I we decided we
said you know Matt I remember because we
were both trying to make it I just lost
my home and try to make it back and he
was homeless so he was I looked at him
he looked at me saying man we gotta make
something that no one will ever forget
like ever I said you're right I said I'm
going all-in he said me too bro
me too we made a pact I remember we made
this pact like because what was weird is
that when you new on the scene
especially with comedians sometimes
everybody's a little sprayed or who's
gonna get to joke and then I guess I'll
that's why I learned at competition
doesn't work especially as an actor you
cannot be competing you must be creative
it kills all creativity 100% if you're
competing with another actor
it's a wrap it is it is you are all you
have to help your guys you have to help
everyone the crew the people stand there
for the lighting do whatever you have to
do to make sure your family you know me
I look what I look at Brooklyn nine-nine
right now that's how that's one reason
why we're so successful and real number
10 the last time before a very special
bonus clip is love I love I say this
before and I'll say it again it's
impossible to to love someone and
control them at the same time most of
these bad things we're talking about our
attempts for people in power to control
other people so that's where every abuse
occurs because you're trying to control
what people think I was trying to
control my wife by not telling her the
truth but love gives you all the options
and then you get to pick and if my wife
loves me like if I kept her in a cage in
the basement
you know that's control that's not love
right but when she can come and go
freely and she comes home because she
wants to be man that's love now I have a
special bonus gift from Terry on how to
tell your story that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching a video to
taking action here we go question number
one where are you going to bring more
love today number two what's the good
habit that you want to develop this
month
and number three what's the temptation
you're gonna remove from your life this
week now if you like this video and
you're also gonna take some action give
me a hash tag believe down in the
comments below when I talk about toxic
masculinity I'm talking about me I'm not
in the game look at you guys and let me
tell you about you and what you've been
doing about me first of all people clown
me about all man oh yeah you got
molested I would have been the guy who
did that stuff yeah I would have been
the guy like man you too big to get man
you're just going to smack somebody and
good out of here I would have been that
person
so I'm never ever pointing the fingers
at another man as if you need to get it
together brother I'm not spreading [ __ ]
but I am saying we need to say we're
guilty Wow
we need to say what it is we did wrong
and this is the only way the only way
I'm really because right now in our
society today we have a big thing about
apologies you know yeah I said I'm sorry
I said I'm sorry I said I'm sorry
so now you got to forgive me and let's
keep going the only way I can really
really kind of put this thing down is
when it's like driving drunk mmm you hit
somebody in the car you get out of the
car
hey man sorry yeah and you get back in
the car and drive away
first of all that is what that is
today's version of an apology mm but
what we're talking about accountability
is totally different yeah accountability
is you stay there with that person unit
accountability is the police come you've
been driving drunk you get arrested
accountability you lost your license
accountability you're paying fines and
you're paying for the person you hit and
you are paying for their recovery yeah
you might be in jail for some time you
might you might listen you you'll be
cleaning up on the side of the freeway
for about six months yeah you know I
mean that's I don't no matter what
status you are
that's accountability you paid the price
mm-hmm and accountability says that that
said now we can get back to to even here
now it's about a mins some balance yeah
you know me and that's that's that's
what I have dedicated my life to doing
yeah my life is funny because when I
look at even the massage parlor that I
went to I learned later I joined
I became an ambassador for the Polaris
Project which deals with sex trafficking
and I it talked about how many of the
women that are involved in that whole
thing are not free yeah they're not free
they were there but they're basically
indentured servants and I'm basically
trying to pay off debts to get out from
some pimp or get out from under someone
who's got their and I played that whole
thing on my hand cuz I said I did that
mm I gotta correct this and so I became
an ambassador for Polaris Project
because to stop human slavery today you
know the fact that they're every at
every opportunity where I can see I'm
really trying to tell my story in order
to just bring light
if you want more Terry Crews check out
the other top-10 I did on him the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
I like this call myself a motivational
doer I hate talking so much when
Hollywood stops valuing me I'm done real
toughness is where you can tell people